russia's alarming military buildup on
the borders of ukraine take a look at
this video showing russian troops
training near ukraine a u.s official
said some of those forces have moved
into possible attack positions
meanwhile diplomatic efforts continue
german chancellor olaf scholes is
meeting with president putin today as
russia insists it wants to keep
negotiating charlie dagetta is in
ukraine for us charlie good morning
another day another european leader
meeting with president putin we'll see
if anything comes of it
good morning to you tony we are in the
city where the u.s embassy has relocated
at least for now due to that huge
russian buildup at the border but as you
said it is a confusing picture this
morning
there has been a dramatic and worrying
shift in russia's readiness to attack in
the past 48 hours
in an overt show of force troops have
stepped up military drills in the region
a u.s official tells cbs news that
russia has now moved rocket launchers
and long-range artillery into firing
positions new satellite images show
ground troops moving from staging areas
toward combat positions and newly
deployed bombers
and yet the russian ministry of defense
released this footage claiming to show
the pullback of some tanks saying troops
are being withdrawn after the conclusion
of some military exercises
amid the uncertainty american i.t
executive heath morrison decided to move
his family here from keeve
are you worried
i don't feel a huge amount of anxiety
right now or worry i
worry a lot for ukraine i i don't like i
don't worry for my personal safety and
you have a son yeah a son he's six years
old i mean
definitely that's a factor certainly
worry about his exposure to
chaos or or anything like that
if there is a mass exodus of people
including americans it's likely they'll
head here
a vibrant city in the west it's thought
or at least hoped to be safer than other
parts of ukraine and it's about an
hour's drive to the polish border
we visited that border to find it all
quiet on the western front nothing
unusual about the line of tractor
trailers and scattering of cars crossing
the border
now there has definitely been a change
in tone this morning the russians are
talking more about diplomacy they're
making a big deal of pulling back a few
tanks and troops but we're going to have
to see what today brings
vlad
all right all quiet on the western front
for now charlie dagger and ukraine thank
you very much